great documentary series they had on the
BBC check this out the filmmakers
created a realistic-looking robot 8 that
allows us to see gorillas up close in
their habitat that the ape has a camera
it's a robot ape that has a camera in it
and it's very hard to get close to these
apes in the wild this enables you to see
what they're up to it's absolutely
incredible check this out Cellini to
show respect our spy events his gaze
decision made
spy gorillas can stay it fooled the Apes
cool the apes normally they they tear
apart like you know someone who's not
supposed to be there they let that ape
stay yeah cuz it showed the correct
behavior and it was really fascinating
and that gave me an idea you can't
possibly know where I'm going we have a
really great crew that works here and
terrific crew they've been with me for
years they do an amazing job they're the
ones that get this show on the air and
well it's hard for me to mingle with
them we have such different lives
so I decided we could use the latest
technology to take a look at their
everyday existence and really see what's
going on with the members of the crew
it's very mysterious let's take a look
as our crew went about their day I added
a new crew member Randy Grady was almost
identical to the rest of the crew with
one important difference a hidden spy
camera we also equip Randy with crew
peace offering a large platter with
Italian subs but the crew is suspicious
they won't move without the say-so of
red Matty the crew alpha but Randy has
another trick up his sleeve I've loaded
him up with several useful phrases
designed to earn our crews trust
thinking of taking a go boat out this
weekend that did the trick
the ice was broken and soon Randy was
fully assimilated into the group getting
right to work with the rest of the crew
taking part in their busy schedules
jamming with the crews party rock can we
sound kick-ass joining him for their
daily meandering bike rides around
gaining respect hey Randy check this out
and even learning the crews most
dangerous and covered secrets it was an
incredible prince in the divinity scene
world with unionized crewmembers and
randy was now one of them
way better than yours Stig eventually
our food is ready cause we're showing
Randy a side of them very few had
witnessed huh she's turning six years
old and March I can't believe they grow
up that fast take a look
we will learned so much about our crew
behavior and then tragedy struck red
Mattie in the group was struck by the
reality that one of their own is death
a quiet contemplatively descended upon
the crew brief empathy sobriety our
cameras captured emotions we didn't know
crewmembers could express then we factor
something even more incredible for the
first time ever our cameras filmed the
story ritual of how crew members care
for their death and in death the crew
gave Randi their greatest honor his own
funeral crew bicycle rest in peace Randy
[Applause]